[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
closing arguments in minnesota versus
kim potter she chose to become a police
officer
and she failed in that responsibility
she betrayed her badge and she betrayed
her oath the jury now deliberates the
former officer's fate in the death of
dante wright plus another settlement
reached between a news organization and
nicholas sandman after claims of
defamation and we're waiting for the
jury's decision after the months-long
trial of former silicon valley ceo
elizabeth holmes then later to the east
coast where the trial for galaine
maxwell winds down
will the socialite be convicted of sex
crimes law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome to law and crime daily i'm
angenette levy in for brian buckmeyer
and with me as always is co-host terry
austin
well the decision is now in the jury's
hands after the defense and the
prosecution made closing arguments in
the trial of kim potter the prosecution
opened by saying that dante wright will
not be with his family this christmas or
any other christmas for that matter he
is no longer with us and prosecutors
also said that potter a 26-year police
veteran was negligent and reckless when
she shot and killed dante wright during
that traffic stop last april prosecutor
aaron eldridge walked the jury through
what happened on april 11 playing the
body camera footage frame by frame
eldridge pointed out that potter's
decades of experience in firearms
training saying she was up to date on
policies but she was still rash and
reckless before finishing eldridge
reminded the jury this case is not about
whether potter is sorry remorseful or a
good person
she told them to make their decision
based on the facts and around potter's
choice to use force
the defendant alone is responsible for
her choices and her actions
dante wright did not cause his own death
we're here because this was entirely
preventable
it didn't have to happen
it was a tragedy of her own making
and it's not just a tragedy
it's manslaughter
that she was an officer
does not make it okay
that she was on duty does not make it
okay
that she shot him with her service
pistol does not make it okay
she chose
right instead of left
she chose wrong instead of right
she chose her gun
and she shot and killed dante wright
following the prosecution potter's
attorney earl grey got the jury's full
attention during his defense's closing
argument gray told the jury it was
rights actions that caused this entire
situation and that had he cooperated it
would have been over and he wouldn't
have died gray emphasized potter was
allowed to use deadly force even though
she didn't know it
another basis for acquittal for not
guilty is
the simple answer mistake
she made a mistake everything they were
doing as good police officers
until dante wright took it upon himself
to flee
he even
left after he was shot
purposely
we thank you for your
careful attention in this case
and if you look at the evidence the
believable evidence and follow the
judge's instructions it's not a
difficult case they failed in every
element
miserably failed
and i'm hoping
that you
come to the fair conclusion of not
guilty based on the evidence
kim potter isn't guilty of these crimes
now the defense objected throughout the
state's rebuttal arguments saying it
wasn't really a true rebuttal because it
was so prepared but the judge overruled
the defense's objections
now as you may recall kim potter faces
charges of first and second degree
manslaughter stemming from the shooting
death of wright during that traffic stop
in brooklyn center just outside of
minneapolis this happened during the
derrick chauvin trial officers pulled
right over for an expired tag they
determined wright had a warrant out for
his arrest body camera footage shows
officers attempting to take him into
custody there was a struggle and then
wright tried to take off
there was uh potter then shot him in the
chest when he got into his car his car
sped away hit another cart in right
right died potter maintains she
accidentally pulled her service weapon
instead of her taser
closing arguments came after emotional
testimony from potter on friday when she
testified
i
remember yelling teaser taser taser
and nothing happened
and then
he told me i shot him
i'm sorry it happened
i was so sorry
i didn't want to hurt anybody
now joining terry and i today is former
prosecutor matt mangino matt thanks so
much for joining us i'm wondering what
did you think of the prosecution's
closing argument
well i thought the prosecution's closing
argument was very effective i mean they
made it clear this case is not about
whether kim potter feels bad or whether
or not she intended uh to kill anybody
you know this case is about
recklessness or criminal negligence is
she culpable for her actions and because
of her long history as a police officer
and in fact
she trained police officers and was
training a police officer on this very
day i think holds her to a higher
standard and you know it you know this
as the defense tries to say was a
mistake but there's no
you know defense is not a mistake is not
a defense in the case like this and you
know i think that the jury has to sort
through everything that they've heard in
this case but really focus on the fact
that she's a trained police officer who
trains other police officers and was she
reckless in her conduct on that day
and terry i'm wondering what you thought
of the defense closing argument earl
grey you know always an interesting
character
you know earl grey's closing was the
worst i've ever seen ann jeannette and
i've heard hundreds of closings it was
rambling it was incoherent and frankly
it was offensive he basically was simply
saying that the scene was chaotic that
the officers were fighting for their
lives and that dante wright caused his
own death worst thing he could have
possibly said and frankly he said that
using either the taser or the gun was
reasonable not a good closing argument
very interesting we're going to see what
the jury does with all of it how they
digest this and what decision they come
to thanks to both of you now we're
moving on to the state of colorado and
that's where
there's a case where millions of people
have signed a petition to
reduce the prison sentence for a man who
was convicted in a crash that killed
four people and injured many many others
now in 2019 rahel aguilera medeiros lost
control of his 18-wheeler when his
brakes failed he came upon traffic that
was stopped because of another crash and
instead of taking a ramp he drove on the
shoulder before crashing into several
other vehicles aguilera medeiros was
found guilty of 27 counts including
vehicular homicide last october the
judge in the case said his hands were
essentially tied when it came to
sentencing aguilera medeiros to
consecutive sentences
now more than 4.3 million people are
asking the governor of colorado to
reduce the sentence calling the crash an
accident the petition claims the company
that employed aguilera medeiros had
several mechanical violations during
inspections the judge can actually
reduce the sentence within 91 days after
the department of corrections evaluates
aguilera medeiros
well still ahead on law and crime daily
we are in verdict watch in the federal
fraud trial for theranos ceo elizabeth
holmes but first a 19 year old man
reaches yet another settlement with a
high-profile news outlet the latest in
the defamation case brought on by
nicholas sandmas sandman when we come
back
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
former high school student a catholic
high school student settles a defamation
lawsuit with nbc nearly three years
after coverage of him that he says
defamed him you may recall nicholas
sandman was a student from kentucky seen
in this video that went viral back in
2019
some watching the video felt he was
smirking at and mocking nathan phillips
a native american man sandman and his
classmates were waiting on a bus after
attending the march for life rally in
washington d.c
many news organizations reported on the
video and suggested sandman was a racist
but a second video actually showed
another group the black hebrew
israelites shouting racial slurs and
other things at people in the area
before the video with sandman and
phillips was recorded sandman tweeted
that the settlement with nbc is
confidential he has already settled
other lawsuits with cnn and the
washington post so let's bring matt
mangino and terry austin back in i'm
really excited to talk with both of you
about this matt i'll start with you it's
really hard to know you know what
exactly these settlements mean without
knowing the terms
but does this third settlement lead you
to believe that nbc knew that something
that they did was wrong that they may
have actually defamed nick sandman
well yes i mean there's
nbc had felt some vulnerability as a
result of this lawsuit we know that two
others were were already settled with
cnn and the washington post
uh but you know there's a lot that goes
into the decision to settle a case and
sometimes it can be as simple as the the
uh legal expenses that might be involved
in defending the case uh based on what
the amount of the settlement is we don't
know that because this is a confidential
settlement uh but there's no question if
you're a hundred percent sure and we can
never be 100 sure in court but if you
really feel strongly that you did
nothing wrong that you were merely
reporting the news
you're going to go to trial
especially if there's a huge demand out
there
but if you feel some vulnerability uh
you might be able to get out of the case
um you know a lot cheaper uh you're
going to go and try to settle a case
and terry i'm wondering what you think
nick sandman may have gotten out of this
if anything what what type of monetary
settlement do you think he may have
received
internet i think it's going to be below
six figures maybe you know 20 30 000
maybe a little bit more i think it's
hard to prove defamation against a media
outlet you have to show that there's a
false statement and it was publicized
and that there was some negligence as
far as that's concerned and that there
were damages and i think here this was a
matter of opinion you're looking at a
video so i think defamation might have
been a little bit difficult to prove i
think they probably settled just because
they don't want to go through all of
that exposure
all right well wouldn't we all love to
know i guess we'll just have to
wait and see if we ever find out exactly
what nick sandman got out of all of this
well coming up on law and crime daily
the fate of elizabeth holmes now in the
hands of the jury as we await a
verdict rather in her federal fraud
trial
plus closing arguments in the sex crimes
trial of gelane maxwell all that and
much more after the break
[Music]
we are back and we are in verdict watch
in the federal fraud trial of former
theranos ceo elizabeth holmes last week
the prosecution and the defense made
closing arguments to
to the jury the prosecution actually
argued that holmes had the chance to be
honest about her company's blood testing
but chose instead to defraud investors
the defense countered saying the
government's case didn't give the full
story saying there were missing
witnesses and that the case was more
complicated than the prosecution said
holmes faces two counts of conspiracy to
commit wire fraud and nine counts of
wire fraud
once touted as a company that would
revolutionize blood testing later tests
found that there were many issues with
theranos's edison device if convicted
holmes could face 20 years in prison and
a fine of 250 000
plus restitution
well terry i'll start with you on this
one uh what do you think of the defense
pointing the finger at elizabeth holmes
former boyfriend sonny balwani they
really said he was the bad guy here
i know it's so strange angenette he's
being accused of physically and
psychologically abusing elizabeth holmes
she even said that he forced sex upon
her now he is 20 years older than her
and they met a long time ago when she
was in high school but i don't think
that's going to work very well i think
that the jury is going to look at that
as though she is just making up excuses
and it has nothing to do with the
allegations in this case
yeah we certainly saw none of that in
their text messages that we've reported
on matt where do you think this case is
going uh what do you think the jury's
gonna do with it
well uh maxwell is pretty confident that
the
is going to find in her favor that the
um
prosecution has improved their case
beyond the reasonable doubt hey this is
this case has been uh going on for three
years uh you know 11 weeks of testimony
29 witnesses for the prosecution you
know i i think the prosecution has done
a very good job of trying to weave
together
why
this jury
should find
elaine maxwell guilty
[Music]
right elizabeth holmes so it's easy to
get them mixed up two federal trials all
right when we come back we are going to
move on to the federal sex crimes trial
of gillane maxwell jurors heard closing
arguments from both sides we will tell
you what our legal analysts have to say
about the summations when we come back
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
jury is now deliberating in the federal
sex crimes trial of british socialite
galain maxwell
maxwell was a longtime companion of
jeffrey epstein and she faces six felony
sex crimes charges prosecutors say she
recruited and groomed young teenage
girls for epstein for sexual abuse
epstein faced similar charges in 2019 he
was found dead by suicide in his jail
cell before his case went to trial
closings came after more than two dozen
witnesses testified for the government
including four women who say they were
abused by epstein with the help of
maxwell maxwell didn't take the stand
last friday after her defense team
called only a handful of witnesses
prosecutors began closing arguments
monday by calling maxwell a dangerous
and sophisticated predator
now long crimes adam klassfeld has been
in the courtroom for the entire trial
and he spoke with us gave us an update
following the government's closing
argument on monday morning
we were expecting this to be a kind of
six-week affair here we are in the
beginning of the fourth week and the
government has just concluded its
summation under the theme of it is time
to hold gallane maxwell accountable
that's the pitch that assistant u.s
attorney elsin moe brought to jurors
saying that maxwell targeted her alleged
victims
seizing upon any vulnerability the
prosecutor said that these stories it
was no accident that these patterns
emerged this was
stories that
that match each other's they uh went
through the extensive evidence we've
heard over the weeks corroborating
important details of each accuser's
story
this is the time when prosecutors put
all of the pieces of the puzzle together
and try to anticipate and undermine
the defense's arguments
in its closing argument the defense said
the government is only going after galen
maxwell after failing to bring epstein
to trial they ended by telling the jury
maxwell was only on trial because of
having a connection to epstein and that
having a relationship with him may have
been the biggest mistake of her life but
it was not a crime so let's bring matt
and terry back in matt i'll start with
you uh they called four accusers the
government did is that enough for them
to prove the case
well yeah that would certainly be enough
to carry uh the burden of proof in this
case um their stories uh seemed to be
consistent there was a consistent
pattern here uh you know what the
defense has to do is really rail at the
fact um
that that some of these uh memories uh
may have some bias to them they may have
been influenced by outside factors and
if you can put the credibility the
believability of those four accusers uh
create some doubt about that with the uh
jury you might be able to carry the day
in terms of of of this defense but it's
but it's important every case comes down
to the believability and credibility of
witnesses was it enough to to attack
with expert witnesses like professor uh
loftus you know the the memory bias of
these witnesses and somehow was it
impacted beyond what actually happened
but what was heard
or what they
talked about or learned about after the
fact
and we've seen uh professor loftus in
many many trials before terry do you
think that galaine maxwell should have
testified
i think it was a very good decision on
the defense not to have her get on the
stand matthew's right it is her word
against their word and
essentially she could basically argue
from her perspective so on the one hand
you would think it would be good to get
on that stand but it's a very risky
proposition under cross-examination she
will be scrutinized she'll be asked why
did she travel with these young girls
what was the purpose behind that and i
just can't understand what her argument
would be what is the purpose who would
take these young girls and travel to
foreign places with them without their
parents so i definitely think it was a
wise move not to get on that stand i
think it would have been a brutal
cross-examination and i don't think
there's any explanation for why you are
conducting massages i don't think she
could deny all of that so good move to
keep her off that stand
right it'll be interesting to see how
long the jury is out well thanks matt
for being with us today and thank you
for joining us
join us next time as we continue to
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you